Santa has to hit 132 million homes
worldwide on Christmas with 31 hours a
night Santa must stop at 1178 homes
every second it's a fraction of a
millisecond to climb down the chimney
fill the stockings eat the cookies and
climb back up sound impossible not for
Santa because he's a master of science
in order to cover his 175 million mile
journey on Christmas Eve Santa would
need to travel seventy eight hundred
times the speed of sound
but that's deadly so Santa probably
creates rips in time and space this
would give him literally months to
deliver presents while only a few
minutes would seem to pass here on earth
good thing we leave out cookies for this
long journey assuming every good kid
gets a toy weighing two pounds Santa's
sleigh would weigh over 660 million
pounds heavier than 1400 statues of
Liberty no way Santa could stay airborne
with that unless his sack was also a
nano toy maker similar to DNA that grows
organs cell-by-cell Sandoz nano toy
maker could transform chimney soot and
other carbons into gifts that's one form
of a gifting we don't mind in order to
keep track of all the naughty and nice
people
Santa probably spies on you more than
the NSA right Ameen text Santa's reddit
post a mean comment
Santa's logged it of course you can't do
it all by himself
theory suggests Santa runs naughty nice
algorithms with more computing power
than Google that's why he lives in the
North Pole to keep all of his servers
cool so the next time someone tells you
Santa isn't real pointed the science
that proves that not only is Santa real
he's also real impressive
Wow